is
[Music]
now sit back and i'm going to tell you a
story
but i'll be honest it doesn't have a
happy ending in fact it doesn't have an
ending at all since 2015 this story has
included over 3 million victims
some of them you may know personally
some of them you've never heard of see
youtube never thought of mug club as any
kind of a threat here in silicon valley
we thought that a few hundred thousand
subscribers wouldn't amount to anything
certainly not something to worry about
but after d-platforming alex jones and
gavin mcginnis as the club grew the
powers that bee knew we had a problem
with over 5000 people a day subscribing
to the channel and thousands of new mug
club members joining each month to say
that mug club had become a bona fide
show would be the understatement of the
year
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
now sit back and i'm going to tell you a
story but i'll be honest it doesn't have
a happy ending in fact it doesn't have
an ending at all
since 2015 this story has included over
3 million victims
some of them you may know personally
some of them you've never heard of see
youtube never thought of mug club as any
kind of a threat here in silicon valley
we thought that a few hundred thousand
subscribers wouldn't amount to anything
certainly not something to worry about
but after d-platforming alex jones and
gavin mcginnis as the club grew the
powers that bee knew we had a problem
with over 5 000 people a day subscribing
to the channel and thousands of new mug
club members joining each month to say
that mug club had become a bona fide
show would be the understatement of the
year
[Music]
we had no idea how so many mugs were
being transported right under our noses
that is until we found
black oh mugskibar
see youtube always thought that mug club
would be paywall content a problem that
would solve itself once everyone got off
the platform but black oh mugskibar had
other plans mugskibar was organized with
contacts all over the intellectual dark
web and members with eyes and ears
everywhere he even hired a cutthroat
half asian lawyer demonetization and
heart strikes didn't even seem to make a
dent and by 2019 the elites in silicon
valley knew they had a real problem
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
club
social
enduro
is
no
youtube heroes
[Laughter]
ah
youtube
facebook
is
[Music]
changes
[Music]
hmm
nice that's a monday sip yes that's a
monday set because uh it's monday and
usually that makes you want to have a
shotgun with a nice toe trigger but uh
i think it's going to be a good day for
everybody involved
and uh hold on a second they're bringing
this up uh oh okay uh if just so you
know especially after uh that's an older
intro that we're rerunning the whole
series of mug clubhouse for those that
you love watch narcos it makes no sense
the entire series is in spanish just to
warn you
and i had to learn spanish just for a
parody to piss off youtube you did okay
we did our best
uh but i learned spanish by watching it
yeah that's what i'm hoping too with my
little ones i just put them in front of
my mug clubhouse and go see
look at that it's multilingual education
no
uh if for any reason
i don't know why you don't see us on
youtube at any point this week you can
just tune in on rumble okay for the free
show or the extended show with a whole
other hour on mug club monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern we tell you if
there's no show if you come into youtube
you say where's the show it's on rumble
it's on mug club okay
all right just want to make sure that
i'm clear about that before i move on
with anything else my question is what
do you know about the situation in
canada the canadian truckers the freedom
coalition what's going on there it's a
big deal and i've always said this
canada is an important petri dish
sort of look to here in the united
states because a lot of americans think
well we're not the same as europe we're
not the same as these other countries
how bad can it get
i think if you look to canada it's bad
enough you don't need to look to
australia you don't need to look uh to
what's going on in places in europe you
can simply look to canada
and see how bad it's gotten
and now the people have been pushed too
far and by that i mean not a french
minority we'll talk about that there is
basically the first revolution
starting to take place in canada they
didn't have a revolution no they're
getting around they still have the queen
on their money yeah you know we fought
off the world's greatest superpower here
in the united states one century to
become the only world superpower uh the
next century unprecedented canada said
like okay
uncle
give us the easy beaches eh but now
they're saying well maybe we were wrong
about that man it'd be a shame if
canadians had ever actually kept their
rights to uh firearms so we'll be
talking about that we'll be talking
about spotify and uh by the way uh
gerald a is here with us how are you i
am well sir how are you good i got a
little bit of sleep this weekend good
you took a good beating there i got a
little bit of sleep and i also found out
that with the with the babies
that uh you know particularly young the
young girl she loves music oh really and
so i soothe her with my
my song yeah
and uh i have a great playlist it's
really easy to make baby songs you just
replace songs with lady with baby there
you go so she's once twice three times a
baby i don't think she's a baby yeah
and then you can also use a song to have
babies so here comes my baby your your
humor is kind of veering towards dad
jokes well it works for the kid is my
point yeah maybe not she's a baby
audience
she's a baby and then i said straight
baby got back yes
that's a great one too yeah don't you
just have to eliminate some of the
verses and uh you hear him he's coming
into the show now you love him you love
him he will be this friday and saturday
at the improv in denver
mr dave landau how are you good ahoy how
are you and also we're going to be if
you saw in that little thing at the uh
victoria theater and evanville's
we've got some big announcements coming
and that was kind of a bit of a teaser
oh so i will be performing with dave
i'll be doing stand-up with dave yeah uh
in evansville indiana is that march 26th
i believe it's march march 26th uh
tickets are now on sale and soon enough
we'll have a web page uh uh not today
but tomorrow probably a lot of
powder.com but you'll be able to see
the shows dave and i are doing together
and then the shows that dave is doing by
himself because you know i can't be gone
too often no no no we have a limited
tour for you uh and uh it's gonna be fun
yep and uh majestic in dallas has
already sold out for dave special and
then we have one in michigan so i'll be
doing probably about ten weekends here
this year
uh getting back into you know doing um
doing more stand up since the pandemic
yeah doing the damn thing doing the damn
thing which is this show that's about to
come up uh
i warn you there's a lot to get to did i
say ahoy good not a slow news day not a
slow weekend uh but before we get to all
of that the canadian revolution that's
taking place with semi trucks and
spotify just absolutely biting the hand
that feeds them
uh first there was this old lady
um who has gotten tired of canada's
insane policy
and uh she stops well look it's in
campbell river in canada uh
just here is an old lady who looks like
the you know in bugs bunny when the lady
grabs the old lady grabs a shotgun yeah
it's pretty much that she's stopping a
thief in a walmart and i hope we can
find her and have her on the
show love how she's more angry about the
hats than the crime
[Music]
i love it
i love how she has the clarity of
thought amidst her rage to explain
supply-side economics yes yes do you
understand what you're doing to us i
love that he just got overpowered by an
elderly woman right yeah he's like wow
you win i can't i'm only two feet taller
than you i was overpowered and i learned
the concept of scarcity wow i should
really straighten up and fly right
i am biking for my own health and to
help with pollution yes
did i live out before the crime she
takes off it's like stop committing a
felony and no hats at the dinner table
let everybody see you wash up for dinner
[ __ ]
it's the only time someone's asked you
not to wear a mask in a walmart in the
last two years right yes
although it's pretty tough to tell when
people are wearing masks versus like
just the people of walmart sometimes
yeah yeah that's true well i think
what's particularly funny is she went
back to greeting right after that she's
like oh well
[Laughter]
get out of here [ __ ] you just create
a skate here's your sticker
the entomens are aisle five yes
i think the what's the minimum age for
walmart readers at 92. it's got it yes
it is
same as presidents now i believe you
have to show them how many you have to
have at least four lethal illnesses yes
[Laughter]
you can either show them your aarp card
or your open heart surgery
yes one hand is completely purple from
bruises
that's what happens basically if you die
as a walmart greeter uh they don't check
for id they just sort of they sort of
ate they check your age like a tree they
go by liver spots and they say oh here
we go
not quite enough yet she probably had
some bruised knuckles on that guy i mean
that you know it's like paper thin it's
like paper mache in those old ladies oh
yeah yeah you imagine if his buddy saw
him like get punked by an old lady yeah
what i hope happened is he ran she was a
distraction you know like doink the
clown had the little clown and i hope he
ran around the block and someone just
boom clotheslined him well there you go
and she was like ha ha
he thought you only had to deal with me
i thought she became asian for a second
good for her she might be she just pulls
off her mask it's jackie chan but you
know what though we all laugh about this
but if it were a bigger stronger man
doing it
the people if if it were a big strong
white man and the victim happened to be
or the thief happened to be let me
restart this yeah yeah if the felon
happened to be the wrong color correct
and the person stopping them had to be a
happen to be a big strong man he would
be vilified yes but the truth is it
shouldn't change the morality it really
shouldn't an old lady doing the right
thing or a young strapping lad doing the
right thing this is the problem with
identity politics i want everyone to do
what that old lady did yeah and not
force the old lady to be the only person
stepping up and doing it it's like we
shouldn't be asking old ladies to do
this they're just pissed off and don't
care well i don't think they asked her i
think she took uh you know what good
initiative old broad yeah yeah i don't
think the people at walmart were like
hey old lady go take care of this no no
but society by not doing the right thing
is like all right well
we're just going to let it happen just
wait until a guy you know runs into the
wrong greeter with an oxygen tank just
yeah
she's getting a lifetime supply of
metamucil on the house
lifetime is uh you know we don't know
yeah well that's why they don't mind it
oh yeah it's like in other words four
months yeah yeah
you get you get free metamucil and
alprazolam that's what we should do we
should turn loose like terminally ill
but still functional people and let them
go take care of some of these like
shoplifting like a geriatric suicide
squad well not suicide i don't want them
to die i just want them to be like no
but you're chancing it off you're
chancing it well that's true but i mean
what what a good way to go out you want
to lay in a bed for four months or do
you want to go out and stop a
shoplifting oh my gosh i would just love
a guy to just turn himself into a human
cannonball and he'd break every bone in
his body but he would take out the yeah
see me stephen in suicide squad not
suicide bomber
yeah yeah yeah like the yeah
they're like you're on death row action
heroes or you can go out and carry out
this really cool mission only you say it
to all the you know the members of the
rotary yeah not like you're terminally
ill and you fit them for dynamite
oh no no no no
they wouldn't get to the they wouldn't
get to the spot they just
on the way somewhere is there a bowling
bar with a bowling ball with a candle in
my depends all right it's weird i have
some ticking orthopedics yes
i don't remember my my my replacement
hip making this sound it's like the
clocks and hook
all right
okay speaking of shoplifting here brings
up uh this brings us to the next point
uh this guy who uh
oh my gosh just everything about him is
obnoxious but uh an actor michael
rappaport who's a well-known lib who
hates donald trump who goes on these
tirades uh he actually filmed the thief
though he was shocked
strolling out of a new york city uh drug
store
stealing stuff he was he was actually
surprised
yo
i'm looking at
this dude
this [ __ ] yo that this dude
i can't believe
i'm seeing this
this my
yo he cares less than the grandmother i
wouldn't be able to believe it if i
didn't build his two bags up
with everything and i'm recording
right here
80th and 1st avenue is walking down the
street like it is gucci look at me in my
face like what
you ain't blocked good he's i was
watching him the whole time
my man just went christmas shopping in
january
he's got the condoms
the shampoo
yeah by the way he speaks of course like
he's an african-american do you know how
you know he doesn't have a hood pass he
said my man
yeah well he probably hasn't seen uh
somebody walk out of a business like
that without paying since the last time
he did stand up right well i know what
they were not stealing uh any of his
films
not a lot of resale value from dvds for
lucky numbers and uh what's another
classic this the sixth the sixth day
that's right he was in the sixth day
yeah you know what was good his uh his
sitcom fox to come the uh the war at
home yes no it was like uh it was like
uh uh sort of like married with children
if uh al bundy was in out of shape
ginger who thought he was black yeah
yeah it's good without the punch lines
right yes without the punch lines
well he could to be fair they could have
been stealing some of his films if the
guy walked out with the entire bargain
dvd bin
incidentally right it was an accident
yes he didn't mean to i don't want to be
fact checked because some of the guy a
criminal was like actually look i've got
six today you're like okay i'm sorry
yeah they actually may have arrested him
if he brought in a bunch of his movies
and left him on the shelf
just take just take what you want just
leave us alone please what's up what
what we have an ep we have an epidemic
of people bringing in michael rappaport
films that's not fair into our dwayne
reeds and rite aids and ruining our
reputation look we'll give you a cop
land that's good yes
was he even caught playing yeah
okay
look he's in some good movies i'll give
him that but but if we're gonna but
they're good in spite we're here to make
fun of him yes
he's he's been in new york for the last
two and a half years and he surprised
someone stealing yeah
who's he rip van winkle i know where
were you sleeping what what's going my
man is stealing stuff from the from the
rite aid which is crazy you voted for it
right yeah you hated trump so much you
wanted the other guy the deal was
up to 900
remember yeah yeah
i remember i would just go to work and
i'd be like oh look they're looting
hudson's again or macy's or whatever
place i couldn't tell the sign was on
fire
are you kidding
oh my gosh that's how you shop in new
york now you know what there's actually
never been a greater argument for the
electoral college than the current state
of new york and los angeles you know
we've talked about this before where
people say oh the electoral college and
unfortunately you know some states are
overly represented think about it when
you talk about swing states okay and
this is the problem people have the
electoral college they complain that
people focus on you know a handful of
swing states those are actually
transient when you look at some states
that were put in play that were not seen
as swing states with donald trump and
then when you look at georgia going uh
bl well georgia going blue
purple safely and securely
i'm just saying these swing states
change because populations change they
have contrast that with major cities
yeah now cities like new york chicago
los angeles would have disproportional
control over how to run the rest of the
country and they've run their own cities
into the ground why should those
policies be implemented in wyoming
montana idaho even texas there is no
greater time in history to argue the
necessity of the electoral college than
today because of los angeles san
francisco new york chicago you want you
want politicians just pandering for
those votes we know exactly how it ends
up rappaport is pro-police to be clear
right our researchers pointed that out
but uh i'm i'm going to go on a limb and
bet that he didn't vote for the
republican candidate for governor of new
york he's probably a pro police union
well remember that may be true as well
right but you do remember when he saved
an entire aircraft of people when
somebody was going to open up the door
and he stopped them ah remember he said
that where i i guarantee you they just
thought it was the bathroom yeah and
then they were like i don't know michael
rappaport tackled me yeah and then i
shed my pants my man is trying to open
the door and go outside into the sky
what's good you can't i'm just trying to
use the bathroom what are you gonna take
a poop in the sky you can't do that
does that look like a bathroom what are
you talking about pooping in the sky all
right let's get him
why are people walking out of this place
like my movie just came out
hey everybody you can't walk out of the
plane now for two reasons one we're in
the sky in two six days on that's that's
the in-flight entertainment
i just called something gucci and i'm
white and in my 50s yeah that's how you
create suicide bombers i can't even
picture him in mine just show
oh really does he look kind of like bill
burr he plays his brother in the heat oh
that's right i don't know that another
another forgiveness the point is
okay speaking of the pits spotify this
is a big controversy right now and it
shouldn't be a controversy at all give
me my opinion on what what i would like
to see happen with joe rogan but um you
know neil young last week threatened uh
he said he was pulling his stuff from
spotify because of joe rogan's podcast
joni mitchell joined neil young removing
her music from spotify uh saying that
they are irresponsible people uh sorry
irresponsible people on spotify are
spreading lies that are costing people
their lives and then barry manilow also
followed suit and spotify stock shut up
nine thousand percent so that was them
wow
next up cher
oh no a bit of an anchor
oh jeez
i hope gordon lightfoot doesn't it was
he dead
[Laughter]
oh we're going to get into that never
mind we're going to get out no we get
into that that's what's interesting
about spotify and who owns a share of
warner music and spotify but um first
joe rogan responded to spotify
announcing they announced that they are
going to label and this is just so silly
now label certain content to be
sensitive that it might what is our
official label do we know what it is
what the spotify labels
it's a warning because god forbid adults
actually are able to watch somebody with
whom they disagree right we need to now
warn adults remember back when it was
tip or gore and it was video games they
started self-regulating saying e for
everyone and you know okay duke nukem
all right we'll put up 17 plus on there
there are strippers and nukes so okay
but
right now we're talking about adults
needing to be warned because they might
hear a differing opinion so spotify said
they were going to slap a warning label
on these kinds of uh podcasts and like
joe rogan and joe rogan responded
to this and discussing uh kovid 19 in
the reaction i think there's a lot of
people that have a distorted perception
of what i do maybe based on sound bites
or based on headlines of articles that
are disparaging
um the podcast has been accused of
spreading dangerous misinformation
specifically about two episodes a little
bit about some other ones but
specifically about two one with dr peter
mccullough and one with dr robert malone
i had them on and because of that those
episodes in particular
those episodes were labeled as being
dangerous
they had dangerous misinformation in
them
the problem i have with the term
misinformation especially today is that
many of the things that we thought of as
misinformation just a short while ago
are now accepted as fact like for
instance eight months ago if you said if
you get vaccinated you can still catch
covid and you can still spread covid
you'd be removed from social media they
would they would ban you from certain
platforms
now that's accepted as fact well you
know he's just that's just conjecture
it means that instead of the vaccine
being able excuse me it means for
instead of the virus being able to hop
from person to person to person to
person spreading and spreading sickening
some of them but not all of them and the
ones that it doesn't sick and don't know
they have it and then they give it to
even more people because they didn't
recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means
the vaccines will get us to
the end of this now i do want to take a
minute to talk about something you know
that that little boy was addressing um
a couple of things here
when they say dangerous
and misinformed let's analyze this both
dangerous and misinformation
misinformation means that the
information
generally speaking is not only false but
knowingly false misinformation right
certainly that's how it's been labeled
uh
here over the last several years with
covid okay now dangerous dangerous would
imply what that it causes damage to
people now let me give you one side
that's been labeled misinformation and
dangerous and this is important just
stay with me here really quickly
joe rogan and ourselves so for example
peter mccullough we had on the show okay
long before uh joe rogan i think we were
the first people to to to have him on
what did we say we said people who want
to get vaccinated should uh get
vaccinated people who are vulnerable who
are immunocompromised it makes sense
people who are elderly it makes sense uh
that being said we don't know the
efficacy of the vaccines yet and it
doesn't seem as though for example what
we would say is doesn't seem like it
stops transmission entirely but it seems
like it lowers hospitalizations also we
don't know the long-term side effects
that's a fact okay that's considered
misinformation and dangerous who does
that hurt
what they claim is it could hurt
somebody because maybe somebody won't
get vaccinated okay
here's the thing there's a difference
between that encouraging someone to be
skeptical off the bat and instilling
which is what fauci what you just saw
rachel maddow do what all of media did
all of mainstream media all of the big
tech companies a false sense of
confidence they told you you get
vaccinated you can't get sick they told
you you get vaccinated you can't spread
it so the vaccinated could go to
thanksgiving parties the vaccinated
could go out publicly the point is that
was untrue and that could actually
spread the virus because people have a
false sense of security what's more
damaging telling your son to avoid
scenarios where he may be bullied or
telling your son who you know will get
his ass kicked that he is invincible so
we should walk right up to that bully
and tell him to stop then he gets his
ass kicked the point is a false sense of
security which is what has been given to
people is far more dangerous and has
harmed far more people than people like
myself
gerald dave joe rogan saying you know
what
we don't have all the info yet
what's more dangerous genuinely i want
you guys to comment do you guys see how
how dangerous that is the false sense of
security throughout all of this the
vaccines are coming we're going to open
back up the vaccines don't let you catch
the virus the vaccines don't let you
spread the virus the vaccines what she
just said they stop the virus no more
variants well that hasn't happened so at
a certain point you have to look at it
and say all right you've blamed all of
this on the unvaccinated but that's no
longer the issue
would it be the vaccine i don't think
that he even broke any of their rules so
it was it was uh announced yesterday
that spotify would have these warnings i
don't think they've gone into practice
yet but this is from spotify's website
dangerous content
and they have coveted down here content
that promotes dangerous false or
dangerous deceptive medical information
that may cause offline harm or poses a
direct threat to public health includes
but may not be limited to
and i don't think he's broken of these
asserting that aids cover 19 cancer
other serious uh life-threatening
diseases are hoax or not real
encouraging the consumption of bleach
and it'll cure various illnesses and
diseases promoting or suggesting that
vaccines approved by local health
authorities are designed to cause death
encouraging people to purposely get
infected with kevin 19 in order to build
immunity to it
um
so it says it may not be limited to so
they're kind of hedging it there yeah of
course that's what they always do with
youtube they say or uh anything else
that we think right some same same
playbook are they gonna pull my show uh
aids as fake drink
yes
i would go with the difference you were
banging on all cylinders oh man but it's
so clear just the politics of that yeah
encouraging
dog this the implication there's just
like donald trump praised white
supremacist nazis he never did he never
told anybody to drink bleach and by the
way that's not even you guys haven't
even agreed upon the right lie because
some people are saying that he told you
to inject bleach and then some people
say oh they're telling you to drink
bleach none of it is true you know that
it's a bunch of human resources people
writing that up so that they can ban
people with a point of view go ahead
dave yeah but also the idea of uh
putting a warning on this just like the
parental advisory warning but that they
decided to put on cds like tip or gore
that doesn't make kids not want to
listen to it watch it the other way
around
for the ones with the parental warning
it was the greatest sales
i mean nothing made i don't know if
that's the case anymore though carlin
had the cd that came out it was just his
face over the parental advisory lab
right no i think it is again i don't
know what's the case with today's
generation a lot of young kids like to
virtue signal and think about it you
have anti-fascists for crying out loud
supporting mandates you have rage
against the machine
demanding that unvaccinated people be
quarantined and locked down i don't know
if it's the same without i put rachel
maddow please stay out of my bird feeder
every morning and she's there every
morning well okay
she's a contrarian that big [ __ ] will
eat so much bird feet i know i love the
look on her face by the way it's not
gonna hop around and get to like other
variants that become more violent and
i'm like oh gosh that just did not but
now it would be considered
misinformation if you say hey why are
there more variants now when there are
more people vaccinated than ever why are
there some doctors and why are there
some published papers saying hey you
know what if you have a vaccine that
isn't or mrna injection that isn't
entirely effective that viruses mutate
and learn to learn to basically get
through
the holes in the defense mechanisms this
is i'm not saying that this is accurate
i'm saying that doctors are afraid to
even discuss it now because that could
be removed as misinformation today even
if we find out tomorrow that it's
correct yeah a question can't be
misinformation right
i mean it can if you're like jesse
ventura where it's like i don't know
was george w bush behind tower seven
with an acme plunger and the saudi
prince i'm just asking questions all
right
but
but i agree with your sentence it's a
leading question well here's something
else that matters follow the mind lead
the witness i get it follow the money uh
so joni mitchell and neil young's music
they're owned by uh warner music yeah
okay
blackrock holds a 1.39
stake in warner music and of course
blackrock elizabeth warren deems too big
to fail they also have a bunch of real
estate holdings that are worth trillions
of dollars i don't know what the number
is today uh and they hold a lot of sway
over there is no more powerful entity
right now as far as business interest
when people talk about ooh corporate
oligarchy means look at blackrock look
at elizabeth warren wanting them to be
too big to fail look at their ownership
here with warner brothers music okay
shouldn't sound like a lot 1.39 that's
74 million dollars of spotify now if you
don't remember 2008 music yeah what did
i say spotify oh well i'm going to get
to that in a second
yeah well it does gritty slip
foreshadowing does explain why two
people as high as neil young and rogan
can't find common ground all of us yeah
yeah remember they used to tell us
people who get high they never they
never fight it's always drunk people
it's like yeah they fight sometimes yeah
not well really not rogan just neil
young out of nowhere for some reason
yeah oh weird yeah i wonder what the oh
right he's owned yes except when i saw
him live though he sang an
anti-starbucks song but this is totally
acceptable right yeah no exactly he
wants starbucks is not even a fraction
of what blackrock is right
now i'm singing for the black rocco
yeah
stockbox is bad
so 2008 blackrock ceo larry fink that's
an [ __ ] name he said that blackrock
would punish companies that aren't quote
woke enough he said to prosper over time
every company must not only deliver
financial performance that's what a
company should do but also show how it
can make a positive contribution to
society and this of course was with a
liberal uh woke angle just last week
blackrock punished 53 companies for
quote climate inaction wow climate in
action what does punished mean
i i don't i don't know that i want to
find out yeah can we find out exactly
what the punishment was probably some
kind of fine or some stern talking too
did they do like an admonishment thing
where they're like oh admonish i love
how the un doesn't punish north korea
when they're launching rockets like the
fourth of july but if a company doesn't
do a you know use a tree plant a tree
bin right they're gonna be punished by
this powerful corporation daddy
blackrock had them pick a switch from
which yes pretty well they wrote a stern
letter stephen signed by all people
there now this is to go back to your
point you know who else uh uh blackrock
blackrock owns a huge share in
the spotify oh one spotify 1.37 or about
611 million worth of stock in spotify
now here's the thing
think about that because everyone talked
about how joe rogan all this money and
he's dangerous right this is this is
everywhere on social media joe rogan's
dangerous because he has this money and
he's unaccountable joe rogan got i think
it was 100 million deal with spotify but
then he also got some stock options so
let's call it anywhere between 150 to
200 something million dollars right yeah
that's still a drop in the bucket
compared to
611 million dollars from
blackrock who also have a conflict of
interest because they have ownership
stakes in other music production
companies
this is something that is very dangerous
now if i were joe rogan at this point if
they start slapping label keep in mind
they asked rogan you know to remove
40-something episodes which he did keep
in mind that spotify has had problems
their employees threatened to walk out
with joe rogan and now they're issuing
these warnings it it wouldn't be beyond
the realm of possibility and legally
probably defensible if joe rogan said
all right
took his ball and walked he's the most
valuable on-air commodity to spotify
certainly and block blackrock thinks
they have more sway because 611 million
dollars right in shares that they have
in spotify but if joe rogan says okay i
came over here because youtube was being
you know they were censoring me too much
the premise was that spotify would be
free and open they wouldn't bother me
and tell me what to say now it's
becoming too constraining now it's too
much of a headache
i'm going to walk and go do my own thing
somewhere else sue me guess what could
be breach and there might not be
anything that spotify can do about it
because they have changed the terms i
don't know the exact contract but i
don't think at least in the court of
public opinion spotify would be in
trouble you're playing with fire spotify
this is the disconnect between the woke
companies who pull the strings and the
woke people who work in your offices and
the people who listen to spotify when
they keep talking about all the money
that he has he's bringing in this money
through his entertainment that he's
getting a percentage of right that's
it's completely legitimate what he's
earning of course these people going at
them is a completely different narrative
and a completely different idea than
what he's doing yeah i mean well barry
manilow has earned spotify a pretty
penny and by that i mean one pretty
penny it was pretty shiny though he
framed it it came right out of a loafer
yeah the punishment by the way would
have to do with
affecting those companies voting action
in the fund and and blackrock is worth
nine point four six trillion dollars
nine point four six thousand assets
under management basically for blackrock
wow that is insane ass hats well the
good news is elizabeth warren right the
socialist folks they're looking out for
you because they want blackrock to be
too big to fail which means they can
continue acting like this and when they
bankrupt companies or when they have the
next crash you get to bail them out with
your tax dollars because they're too big
to fail looking out for you hey by the
way as much as i hate them this show is
available on spotify so please
subscribe on spotify on apple on android
anywhere that you get your podcast
because again if you're not on rumble if
you're not on mug club you can listen to
the audio version and sometimes there
are little uh little easter eggs there
in the uh the audio version watch also
available on elizabeth warren's smoke
what the heck is going on out there
what's going on out there
are they they just told me the
hodgepoints are here oh the house the
hodgepodge
what's going on
hey uh austin what are you doing i'm
just waiting for the bathroom they're
both to lose right now so
perfect
oh crap i need some privacy in here
oh
what are you doing i i didn't know you
both
peed together
yeah
so big yeah
[Music]
could someone get some tramadol for
those hodgdons just calm them down a bit
just hey our researchers also found
something kind of funny about neil
young's past um so you'll remember i
just brought this up about you know the
content that's dangerous about him he
did drugs yeah that's so confident
peppercorns too content that's dangerous
about aids they just sent me this uh
neil young blamed homosexuals for aids
in an interview with melody maker i know
he wasn't all bad neil young backed
reagan's gun control policies instead of
aids you go to the supermarket and you
see a homosexual slayer behind the fn
cash register you don't want him to
handle your potatoes hold on a second
let me let me see this i'll i'll read it
like neil young you go to a supermarket
and you see a [ __ ]
behind the [ __ ] cash
register
[Music]
that's the word that he said you're
quoting neil young also that's pretty
bad by the way you don't want him to
handle your potatoes and in the 80s we
all know that potatoes meant balls yes
true it still happens to mean balls
potatoes are hard to come by
don't touch my potatoes gay men i want
to make mesh later now what's he doing
now is he still blaming aids on the gays
no but it was 1985. let's be fair we all
did yeah well you know i was three and i
was like don't touch my potatoes yeah
also in 1995 2005 2015 and 2025 uh
statistically your chance of catching
aids in the united states if you're
heterosexual male non-intravenous drug
user is zero so good for you well and
the reality is let's be honest it's not
neil young doing this it's the people
that own his music
no neil young came out and made a
statement yeah but i feel like he's
being forced to i honestly believe that
really i don't care i i mean i think
he's being i mean i don't think he's he
has a soul remember when we used to
remember we used people used to get mad
where they would like call green day
sellouts because they sold a few extra
albums yeah they were saying now it's
like neil young and jody mitchell
well i think crosby stills and nash
loved it when gay men handled their
potatoes i can't imagine they were upset
nope
all right
what what are we gonna say no no how
much money was joni mitchell making on
i don't know
but i hope she uh finds a river she can
skate away on and fall in i'm great
we'll get rid of and i can't i can't
even think of a song she wrote i know
the name
name one what's your name my joke fell
on deaf ears no i caught that that was
one
[Laughter]
i knew one and you named it and now i
don't know more she has that one says
chelsea morning uh-huh uh she has that
one the river she has chelsea i knew the
river and then she has a
i don't know
good voice
dumb person was the book the kids are
all right
never mind who cares all right let's
move on to
trudeau and truckers truckers great
world leader yes yes fantastic world
leader who's hiding like a [ __ ]
captain blackface when i first read that
he was hiding i thought it was a joke i
thought it was a joke yeah is he hiding
or is he just wearing blackface yeah i
don't know he's hiding by wearing
blackface yeah he's wearing blackface
i'm not just laying down on tarmac as i
say in canada that makes you stick out a
little bit right well they have a lower
population of black people being racist
well depends where you are in quebec
they have a lot of haitians okay the
french canadians don't like them because
they are also racist so my name is leroy
tap shoes i don't know no trudeau
[Laughter]
all right so you've probably seen the
freedom convoy of truckers but there's
more to this story and i think this
matters because a lot of people don't
understand american history and for
example why we have the second amendment
and why it doesn't exist in other
countries
and sometimes that's also important to
understand why we have more violent
crime than say a place like canada and
of course population density matters i
mean canada is a much bigger country as
far as land mass but they have one tenth
of the population to be clear
but you also have a history in the
united states if people use the term
rugged individualism but i mean actual
rebellion and armed rebellion because
when you fight off royalty
when you fight off uh the world's
greatest superpower it's something that
you know could always happen again and
you it having to fight for your rights
quite literally you understand what it
takes and you understand that that fight
never really goes away it's just a fight
that may lie dormant for a bit then you
have a country like canada which
you know for all intents and purposes
very similar to the united states it's
like you know i've heard it described as
america's hat and the truth is uh
they don't have that same history now
maybe you're right maybe they don't have
as much violent crime or maybe they
don't have as much gun crime i should
say depending on the city they do have
plenty of violent crime uh but they also
don't have freedom
and the freedoms get eroded and they get
stripped away more and more and they
it takes place without a fight
because you don't have a nation that's
founded on a fight and guess what i like
that about the united states i'll take
the good with the bad i understand i
understand that guns can be dangerous
and they can be used for bad but i also
think it's a greater like gandhi said of
all the acts all the evil acts uh the
british empire took i'm
quoting him somewhere we'll bring it up
on mud club i believe he said uh
robbing a nation of arms will be its
darkest or be its blackest is what he
said he recognized that robbing a nation
of arms was how you completely removed
their rights you can see it with canada
you can see how far it's gone and now
they're
really uh
having what would be closest to some
kind of
revolution
in canada because it hasn't really
happened at all throughout the history
of the country and at some point when
you have a government who becomes more
and more tyrannical there needs to be
some pushback and it can get ugly thank
god here in canada it has not yet but i
wouldn't be surprised if it does so this
is uh the the the truckers
uh the freedom convoy is what it's been
called but it extends beyond the
truckers who've been protesting the
kovid vaccine mandate in canada for
those who missed it
[Music]
even idea how cold it must be there oh
like it's unreal
shoot not fireworks they're heroes
[Music]
that redhead and old man are the most
canadian looking couple i've ever seen
a lot of gingers yeah you're gonna have
a kid that just talks like that kid in
south park yes
i'm not your buddy guy
i'm not your guy buddy no buddy pal
here's the thing trudeau uh just to be
clear because you just saw some truckers
and guys who knows how many people are
in that truck i mean i saw a breakdown
you can fit a few
but trudeau said that this is just a
small fringe minority and this is how
the me notice you haven't really heard
about this in the united states we've
been watching cnn all morning haven't
seen it doesn't mean it didn't happen
but i've watched cnn for at least three
hours this morning haven't seen it once
maybe it got past me
uh like the omicron with the vaccine
trudeau called the group a quote a small
fringe minority and condemned them for
their views only well first hear it from
uh from his
one of the rare instances from his mouth
where he's not in blackface
the
small fringe minority just gay face of
people who are on their way to ottawa or
who are
holding unacceptable
uh views uh that they're expressing
unacceptable do not represent
the views of canadians who have been
there for each other who know
that following the science and stepping
up to protect each other
is the best way to continue to ensure
our freedoms our rights our values as a
country
you just said stand up to protect each
other
after saying
unacceptable views hey look here's one
thing if you are uh a leader of a free
country
you never say unacceptable views
you're now a tyrant
can we all agree on that yeah yes that
is that is terrifying it's dangerous and
that's unacceptable
someone's saying this is an unacceptable
view and by the way the view is just you
can't for this is reverse logic they're
protesting saying hey you can't force us
truckers to get vaccinated we just have
a problem with you forcing this upon us
and then he says these people holding
these unacceptable views hey
what happened we're all in this together
yeah we're all in this together
that is terrifying well and he also said
so you can't hold these unacceptable
views and he said if we follow the
science this is how we get back to i
think he was saying normal or something
no no no what you basically just said is
if you hold these unacceptable views we
will never give you your rights back
that's exactly what we would never let
you go out again and do what you did and
that's why it's important he combines
these like unacceptable views of this
fringe minority oh really fringe and of
course you don't see this covered in
mainstream outlets but thank god for
online media as long as it's still
permissible and doesn't have to be
slapped with a warning label this fringe
minority
[Music]
and there's there's more footage all
references is available at lighting
credit.com that drone turns around
you're talking about
miles all of parliament miles now
to folks here say yeah we had more of
that with the [ __ ] hats this is canada
there are not many people who live there
that's like an entire province well do
do this if in everybody right now go to
your phone go to the computer take out
the map function make sure traffic is
turned on and look at where they are
what is it parliament hill in in ottawa
yeah right look at the traffic around
there and you will see like it is
gridlocked police were issuing
statements like stay away if you can
don't go downtown small fringe yeah
and here's the thing but regardless
sorry no go ahead well regardless of the
people with the [ __ ] hats are the
number of people that that is it's a
free country exactly it shows that that
goes against what they want doing
exactly what they tell you to do is not
freedom no it's absolutely that's simple
but that's why they try and marginalize
and say small
it's a small amount of people who cares
they're allowed to believe that even if
right no yeah the only problem is it's
not a lot quick breaking update the
prime minister blackface has tested
positive for kovid this morning oh
so that's why i went into hiding poor
guy
poor guy by the way you know what's the
funniest thing about this 80 plus
percent of those truckers they estimate
are actually already vaccinated like
i've seen higher estimates up to 90. i
guarantee you that mandate i guarantee
you that walking vagina is that guy's
probably had his ninth booster and he
still got it what he just said hold on a
second can we play a portion that clip
again where he says the science the
later part of his clip where he says the
science is how we get out of this
because remember you said get the
boosters and life will go back to normal
right and like we just showed you saw
rachel maddow saying this we know that
he said this as well you get the vaccine
you get the boosters you don't get sick
you don't get hospitalized you don't
have to quarantine he said something
like that just in that clip that we just
showed right can we see it again uh that
they're expressing
do not represent
the views of canadians who have been
there for each other who know
that following the science oh
stepping up to protect each other
is the best way to continue to ensure
our freedoms our rights our values as a
country well good news for you trudeau
is you followed the trail of pfizer
crumbs all the way at covet door still
yeah how's your cough idiot
how are you how are you any better off
than the 20 remaining whatever number of
truckers who haven't been vaccinated at
this point with omicron how are you
better off
i'm less likely to be hospitalized eh so
so is everyone
it's called homicrony it's where uh the
black face
mixes with omnicron yes and creates a
real dick and it comes with a free tin
of shoe polishing yes
brought to you by kiwi the finest
he is fully vaccinated and boosted and
he actually doubled down in his
announcement and said everyone please
get vaccinated and get boosted
could someone strap him to a booster
chair and drop him out of a carrier
plane yeah i really really hope he gets
well i'm joking by the way please don't
strap him to a no chair i don't know
where you drop him from somebody please
tell me the undisclosed location that he
fled to is in the united states that
would just be the perfect
perfect finish to this that would be
absolutely hysterical but i guarantee
you he's not i fled my country why
trucks
i'm sure he's in a massless party really
trucks one of them was optimus prime and
yeah i don't know if they're going to
transform now or later i dress as a
genie
[Laughter]
all right uh and so what do they do and
this is we know that actual neo-nazis
that actual they're very few and far
between and the pro this is why the
media has tried to make it seem like a
huge problem why because you just saw
that fringe minority
all over not only
the the capital in ottawa but flooding
the streets and of course it's the same
line of attack as always what does the
media do they attack them as nazis right
here from anti-hate canada the freedom
convoy is nothing but a vehicle for the
far right from salon canada's freedom
convoy is this january 6th for the great
white north now um let's be really
[Laughter]
sorry
this is so terrible oh yeah that's a lot
oh yeah when you're when your comparison
for horror isn't really that horrifying
yeah you're like okay well yeah well
first of all january 6th it wasn't like
9 11 and now you're like yeah trucks
driving down the road there age just
like towers right yeah it's just you
never know those beeps are allowed
noise pollution and keeping up the
neighborhoods about to like talk about
the honking yeah like first of all you
live by a freeway if you're bothered by
it
and also
also live anywhere in a city
you're gonna hear honking all day and
now i was all for the revolution until
uh yeah boys guys
you know we were really we didn't we
didn't expect it to come with a few
courtesy honks that's uh you know yeah
i'm for freedom but earplugs that's a
stretch i mean for crying out loud then
they also don't last very long hey you
gotta buy more earplugs they get all
they get waxy yeah there's only like 30
that come in the pick you know i don't
know why we're doing midwestern i'm
never killian here they're kind of the
same aren't they a little bit
so uh let's be clear obviously these
people are not nazis they're just tired
of the and i actually use this term
properly draconian coveted measures uh
and i'll get to those really quickly but
keep in mind they're calling these
people nazis okay
do you know how you know that's not true
just like we went back to rachel maddow
before it's so wonderful
with dead jews that's a start that's yes
so we haven't inspected them i just
you're gonna need a war hey are there
dead jews in that truck hey let me see
your warranty
i'm sorry i didn't mean to help
shut up back there
i just hate how everything is compared
to the holocaust that was a tragic
horrific thing
stop comparing trucks driving down the
street you know what though there is an
untold story of the holocaust yeah it's
true it was
big diary at work that's true yeah they
made a fortune so
[Laughter]
trudeau characterized the unvaccinated
before as
racist and misogynist and insertist here
this is
um
i just i can't even handle them the guy
just there you know i just i just watch
him and then i'm like what is oh an
involuntary fist clinch what happened
so he just said they're often racist
often you can say that about anything
you can say that about rams fans you can
say that about you you'd say it about
michael rappaport fans a lot of them are
racist and then he goes on in that clip
for people who are listening on audio
and french to say we need to decide as
members of government do we tolerate
these people so keep in mind saying we
won't tolerate the unvaccinated and then
he just said these people hold
unacceptable views yeah and he
characterized them as racist as
misogynist and the media of course is
carried as water calling the nazis
exactly in the the i don't know who the
person was if it was the person
interviewing him or somebody else said
they're extremists right right so it's
just basically saying okay
right
what does that have to do with somebody
being anti-mandate does it matter what
other opinions they hold when all
they're really talking about is mandates
you're just trying if anything the the
vaccine is phallic well that's true i'm
not saying that it's not important to
deal with that at another conference i'm
just saying you know what i'm saying
it's a woman hear me roar
i know yeah i've never seen a truck
parked outside of a strip club what a
great observation
all right so it's not even misogynistic
just being attracted to women now is
misogyny yes yeah it's absolutely true
it's honest you know who's still okay
with it if you pay compliments like i
don't pay compliments to white women in
public no older black ladies yes i say
like oh my if you compliment if you say
like wow you have a beautiful skin or
you say well i really like your nails
they're like ah here's some free [ __ ]
you're like thank you i always go you
speak so well yes oh yeah they love that
and they say you're bullshitting
hey i am not ah
you can take the cart you don't don't
worry about doing auto pay it's self
checkout it's under 900 yeah
it's 100
in san francisco i like to hold the door
for anyone except for a blue haired
white girl yes it was just i do it
myself i'm like good i'll close it for
you i do profile i'm not gonna i'm not
lying to you yeah i
profile and it has i i realized this the
other i'm like wow i actually don't
really profile anyone based on race
because i saw a fat woman
woman i saw a fat girl
middle she's like late 20s it's tough to
tell i s rocky and bebop looking nose
ring oh wow purple hair and i
immediately was like
i walked the other direction because i
thought if she recognizes me she's gonna
call her lesbian chain gang so i do i do
profile that way and then i realized
whoa i really don't have a shred of
racism in me because i don't like that
person and it was entirely based on a
generalization uh predicated upon her
looks now let me get to the restrictions
when you say they're nazis you say these
people are racist misogynist or maybe
maybe they just oppose the measures like
in ontario the restrictions included
indoor gatherings were restricted to
five people outdoor gatherings to ten
gyms theaters indoor performance centers
were closed vaccine passports were
required to enter restaurants well they
still are restaurants bars sporting
events basically everywhere and keep in
mind 80 percent of residents are already
fully vaccinated now uh we can go on to
other provinces my province of quebec
where i was raised up until january 17th
residents were curfewed into their own
homes from 10 p.m to 5 a.m
wow
what if you're what if your dog needs to
go to the bathroom doesn't matter yeah
get a pee pad
joe lewis is 115 pounds do you have any
idea the size of the p pad that i would
need
it's going to be a bed
last week the premiere francois lego
announced all unvaccinated adults quebec
would have to pay a financial penalty
just now keep in mind there's a
difference between let's say a financial
penalty for um let's say a financial
penalty like your insurance is higher
because you've had more accidents right
that's something that's not really
wouldn't be considered a financial
penalty but it's something that we
understand is a financial consequence to
your actions let's say financial penalty
like your rates might be higher because
you're a smoker right if you're looking
to get insurance this is a financial
penalty
for existing
you didn't
get injected with an mrna
shot i'm not going to use the term
vaccine you didn't do that you didn't go
and procure a service now they say free
but of course it's taxpayer funded you
are going to be financially penalized
for existing
as you have since you were born
think about that for a second
again let's not act as though it's a
financial penalty for an action that you
had taken it's a financial penalty for
just being you what happened to mr
rogers i like you just the way you are
until we uh get in there and you know
mess with your jeans a little bit yeah
and don't let them lie to you and tell
you that this is just like the insurance
thing with smokers or people who are
overweight they actually ask you do you
smoke they ask you do you drink a lot
they come out and take your blood right
and do some tests to find out are you a
greater risk
i'm not at a greater risk
than most people right there's very few
age groups of people that are at a lower
risk of having as a young healthy male
young healthy male already had coveted
we're not at risk right now natural
immunity by the way none of this takes
into account natural immunity doesn't
matter if you've had it that's not even
a consideration it doesn't matter if
you've had it doesn't matter if you have
antibodies but it doesn't matter if
you're at risk for this or not they're
saying if you're unvaccinated period you
have to pay more right it's like well
hold on no not for rates you're just
going to be financially penalized period
well in this case yes i'm just saying
that they'll lie to you and be like well
we do that for other stuff and that no
no no you actually start segmenting
people out by risk for other stuff so
you need to make a different argument
and this is just think about this
everyone no for crying out loud go go go
ahead dave no i'm just saying the guy
even said to me when he took my blood
he's like do you have you ever had
unprotected sex with a man i said what
no and he goes do you want to
do i get a better rate yeah that guy
wasn't exactly coming from usada i know
the real insurance guy came later but uh
yeah you should have been tipped off by
the purple boa i gotta tell you i didn't
sit for a while yeah well you know what
that was your fault you didn't have to
go through with it i know it turned out
i could have gone on the other way
you're too easily swayed dave i know i
really are yeah i tell you i am gullible
think about this for a second
well i'll i'll i'll get back to this the
frog in a boiling water in the boiling
water you know you slowly turn it up uh
what it takes
look
in this country
you had people they started blowing
folks away with muskets because they
wanted to tax their tea
and right now do you think that you
think that in the united states they
would have stood for this kind of crap
think about that for a second we're
going they wanted to tax something that
was at least a good right they were
purchasing tea and now we understand
okay there are vat taxes and okay we're
gonna have sales tax fine to us we think
that's reasonable now back then they
thought that was extreme can you imagine
the american revolutionaries
having to deal with a monarchy or any
government
of any kind of any form of any modern
iteration saying we're going to tax you
for your existence
this would be like taxing the americans
who said okay fine we're not going to
buy tea if you're and they'd say we're
going to tax you we're gonna penalize
you for not purchasing tea that's what's
happening right now this is absolute
insanity if you don't understand
on which side of the aisle freedom lines
up at this point
you haven't been paying attention
you can't find a middle ground with
people who are okay taxing you simply
for being now let's also go through some
issues here where people might have a
problem uh in canada and not be nazis uh
maybe for example they had problems with
pastors
you guys have the first amendment in the
united states it doesn't really exist in
canada
pastors being arrested for practicing uh
past storing
this guy three times
you get orders from corrupted
politicians corrupted leaders and this
is what you do
out of this property or nazis
out
out
gestapo is not allowed here
immediately gestapo is not
allowed
i like that guy i do too
that was a fitting use of the nazi it
was a fitting use when they're coming in
to arrest you right practicing your
religion exactly it's like ah the brown
shirts it's just in different form now
although that being said it was an app
comparison there but it turns out that
turns out he does do it a lot he's like
orange juice with some pulp
gestapo juice get the pulp out oh i said
no pulp
are there pickles on this burger
so we really do overuse the nazi thing
no
but in that case it's entirely
appropriate when they're arrested
they're arresting you for the fact that
that's disgraceful especially the dude
in the snow it's the same guy same guy
just kidding it's the same guy getting
arrested multiple times every time
that's the same guy three times yes
it was a very short period of time too
yeah
what religion is he i i just want to
know if i should be all right with it
yeah yeah
no dave
that's that's not the best they're
hauling off louis farrakhan
well you know maybe he deserved it i
don't know so of course the media
the media doesn't want you to think that
uh taxing people simply for existing is
fascist that uh arresting passers is
fascist they want you to believe that
all of these people out there protesting
are nazis so let's look at uh quickly
when the media has covered it briefly
the characterizations they were talking
about how a statue of terry fox in
ottawa was defaced by vicious protesters
here's the defacement
yeah they put a flag and a sign on them
oh oh my god oh never get that off even
cleaned off the bird [ __ ] would you look
at that
oh
dear um and they gave terry fox a leg
there was one single swastika spotted in
ottawa the statue which has sent the
media into a full frenzy now here's the
thing if you look at those people with
that swastika flag they don't look like
truckers or protesters you know what
with the black block dress and the face
masks and the hood uh but more
specifically a facebook user named
mickey and of course this is a this is
what's been covered everywhere look at
the swastika flag yeah right
the facebook user mickey anthony claimed
responsibility on ben shapiro's facebook
page because that's where you confess
he wrote these are my my flags and i
have the right to fly them well keep in
mind that user lives in wuhan china has
four followers uh one single post
absolutely a real person yeah good job
legitimate media
just like by the way these folks who are
out there pro are absolutely real
truckers
i think we have this uh collage i won do
you guys have yeah look at all these
folks right there these folks are real
truckers with with a union jack there
the confederate flag in canada which
you've never seen ever
yeah that's odd because it means you
know so much in canada the the media is
clearly look this is a tactic of ant we
don't know of course never it's a tactic
of antifa where obviously we've been in
involved in an infiltrated antifa group
one of their more common practices is
going into counter protests yes and
trying to make them seem extreme this is
something that has been well documented
this is not a surprise this is not a
conspiracy theory you can find more uh
articles and footage on this than you
can watch in a lifetime all references
available at lyderworthcutter.com well
and this was actually in response to so
this made the rounds right and people
saw the nazi flag people who were
helping i guess with the protests and
everything else they said
i think 6 500 bucks or 8 000 was
something that i saw too if anybody can
identify the person who was carrying the
flag because they're like look we don't
want them a part of our group either
yeah let's identify them and see it's
weird they had on full face covering and
sunglasses and hats and you couldn't
identify these people and everybody else
is just out there like hanging out at a
barbecue essentially you'd identify it
as me and we'll split the money well i
think that's what people are like doing
now as a joke on ben shapiro's page dave
will just be there in canada and the
parliament fanning his cash i'm making
snow angel dave it's actually who's even
making those flags start walking around
like uh like curly i'm making snow
swastikas
nobody died
much as you think and here just to give
you an idea too how this has worked they
said well we can't let nazis right we
can't let nazis be out there there's
been one flag out of the hundreds of
thousands potentially millions of people
we can't let that well there was one
flag we have to end freedom right yeah
yeah so uh nova scotia the government
banned people from gathering along the
roads uh in support of the convoy how's
that gonna work yeah well well they're
doing their best because they're
actually laying down nails on the road
hey guys this is a convoy from st jerome
to ottawa and they're putting nails now
on the ground
so we can't get through
show me the nails look at this buddy
show me the nails
again
look i don't care if you are
i don't care if you're a member of mensa
french canadian joao you're going to
sound like an idiot
i have the cure for cancer you know
that's still destruction of property
where the other one is a protest
[Music]
uh like the the age with the homosexual
neil young's gonna talk about it
don't let him handle your potatoes
my god man now
i think uh a poet musician was was it uh
was it
scott gil scott scott
herron said uh the revolution will not
be televised and this is important this
is something that's recovered everywhere
right now here in the united states
because this could be coming to a
theater near you um very quickly all
jokes aside though when the time came
trudeau stepped up like the world-class
leader that he is and he did he did to
his credit he met with the protesters
not now stephen as as we've discussed
there's no no no no no as we mentioned
he went into hiding and maybe even
america who knows oh that's right he
went hiding like a little [ __ ] yeah
sorry i forgot and now he's claiming the
uh now he's claiming that it's because
of covid how much do you want about he's
like quick quick someone with omicron
cough on this popsicle
give me the rona please it's not the
trucks
loud horn it's the popsicle what
popsicle i mean omicron
someone sneeze on my flag that's nazi i
mean i mean uh oh no oh it wasn't me i
was walking at a protest oh
i pretend to be lots of things let's
also be clear by the way the police in
ottawa uh they uh didn't report any
injuries any serious uh nope uh
incidents but the media said that they
were worried about no violence no
injuries well they did put a flag on
terry fox and a sign and they did dance
were there horses they did dance yeah uh
of course it's you know look
i think people are obviously scared of
what's happening in canada and i
understand that because
you know it's pretty dark in comparison
to the uh mostly peaceful protests we
had here after george floyd
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
largely peaceful demonstrations in the
face of law enforcement
why would you ever not trust
media and or spotify i'm just glad it
wasn't like i loved that photo you just
went why it wasn't like january 6. no
god for real mayhem god forbid someone
to show up with a uh with a with a horn
hat viking hat from party city telling
people to be peaceful hey guys
there's another angle of that woman who
was uh you know unj i'll just say it
unjustifiably shot of course
i guess there's another angle supposedly
i don't get thrown off she was trying to
stop a guy from breaking in through the
window some people have said that she
punched him in the face there's video of
it yeah
she was trying to stop the guy from
doing damage and that's what got her
killed
well she did start to climb through she
did start to climb through she was like
well the damage is done oh so it's a
crawl space oh
new we're going to talk about something
here with uh raz simone from chaz
there's an update but i will say this
about canada and you know what i want to
hear please comment guys to our canadian
fans we have a lot of fans in canada uh
if you're watching right now what it's
been like for you there i know i have
some family there not as much as i used
to and most of them are up in more rural
quebec so it's a little bit different
but americans look if you guys talk
about hong kong obviously and they do
deserve our support uh
your canadian brethren right right now
really need you to be their voice
and by that i mean cut through the fog
on social media
all of you have a platform and i know
you're all being throttled i know that
if you start talking about this and you
start quoting the wrong facts i know
that maybe you end up being banned what
i will just say is do your due diligence
okay
keep your head in a swivel and really do
everything you can for these people in
canada because you have a government
who's powerful enough to
silence them and has openly said that
they are seeking to silence them and the
worst part is you have enough citizens
in canada who are willing to go along
with it now i'm not saying it's like
nazi germany but what i am saying is
nazi germany was just like every other
example
of genocide before that
or authoritarian regimes before that
where it starts with getting your fellow
citizen to turn on you and turn you in
and that's what the rhetoric is in
canada and i don't know what it takes
here in the united states
um we do have more safeguards than
canada does and that's a great thing for
example we have the first amendment we
have freedom of religion they don't have
that in canada we have the second
amendment they don't have that in canada
you do not have the right to speak
freely freedom of speech does not exist
in canada and you do not have the right
to defend yourself that does not exist
in canada so those are two important
safeguards and these are safeguards that
every single member of the current dnc
wants to do away with let's be clear
about that
the boiling frog analogy this is
happening in the united states where
look
i'm gonna try and reduce try and distill
this for you it's 2022.
we were told two weeks
the water is boiling
okay
what happened in canada is they were
just taken from a slightly warm pot and
thrown into boiling water when they go
wait a second i'm gonna be taxed for not
taking a vaccine wait a second hold on a
second you're arresting pastors and so
all of a sudden it was a reaction like a
hand on a hot stove ah get off me and
now it's been enough to push them for
them to be a catalyst here for hopefully
some kind of freedom revolution and by
the way they've been talking all these
truckers right these convoys have been
saying peaceful non-violent but they
have been forced to take a stand and by
the way that can seriously disrupt a
supply chain keep in mind there are
other forms of pressure that can be
exerted that do not require violent
revolution and those need to be
exhausted to their full list because hey
we're all in this together we're all in
this together well maybe the truckers
don't want to get vaccinated hope you
don't mind waiting an extra couple weeks
for your next stock up at trader joe's
canadians right now need your help this
is some this is a revolution taking
place and it's not being televised a lot
of them there are so many americans who
have no idea we used to when i used to
live in montreal there was a place
called plattsburgh new york po dunk town
it's 45 minutes from the border uh 45
minutes actually from where we lived in
montreal
and we would go there we'd go to the
mall because they only had like the gap
when we were young or they had taco bell
things he didn't have in the united
states you know so he thought it was
really cool and we would ask them if
they'd ever been to montreal they would
say no they never even thought to go up
to canada these are people who lived
right there
the contrasting histories
of canada and the united states and the
contrasting significance and impact that
they have had on the world for the
better tells you why the united states
did it right and canada did it wrong the
safeguards that we have now
tell you why we have done it correctly
and we need to protect those safeguards
whereas canada right now needs to do
away
they need to do away with their
institutions their institutions say you
can't fight back their institutions say
your prime minister parliament these
premiers can tax you for existing
their institutions say the prime
minister can go out there and deem your
views unacceptable that's what their
institutions say so when the media tells
you oh it's such a problem that people
are losing faith in their institutions
well
the institution of what
what matters is what that institution is
right
stalin's russia there were institutions
hey jim crow was an institution when you
look at the laws institution slavery was
an institution
all we're talking about with an
institution is something that's
established right typically we're
talking about something that's
established legislatively or culturally
when they talk about the institutions
like people lose faith in media there's
nothing wrong with losing faith in the
institutions if the institutions are
unworthy of any kind of faith and that's
where they are in canada and i really
hope that you guys uh give them your
support by the way hey smash the like
button too right now if you're on
youtube because that kind of helps and
you know show canada that you love them
no wait wait wait wait what are you
doing
we're not leaving not yet good lord he
needs to work this trick
i was on a roll
that was my fault i threw my shoe out
gofundme is also trying to freeze
um and so there is a guy matthew fleury
who is a ottawa representative who's
trying to get
the government to take action so that
the taxpayers aren't left holding the
bag
what does that mean exactly he's
he's trying to target and get the money
from the gofundme account that race to
support the truckers to pay for what he
says is the damage that the truckers are
doing oh okay okay okay correct is that
a pretty good summation it looked like
he was trying to go after that money
well uh why don't you just go create
your goal own gofundme consciousness
matter is he trying to i think he's
trying to get gofundme to stop trying to
freeze it because
gofundme is
hey you know what they should just do is
they should just switch the title from
raise money for the truckers to raise
money for four-year-olds uh sex surgery
four-year-old sex change operation oh
gofundme won't touch that with a 10-foot
pole and they'll make sure that the kid
gets a 10-foot pole all right this is
you guys all remember our favorite
warlord razz simone yes
i whenever i read the name i'm always
thinking of that person who was uh uh on
the view and that's raven simone oh
that's such a raven thing you're such a
viewer you're so raven i know too much
raven you mean the guy who got like a
forty thousand dollar grant from the
government to be a rapper yeah and then
became king of uh king of razz and
handed out ar15s to underage children
yes one in the saints that dude yeah
cool yes i'm a fan of him also yeah big
big time so uh now he's being sued okay
let me explain but why
he's being sued by five women
four of whom say
that he trafficked them now if only he
trafficked three more women and beat
them with uh beat them with curling
irons and stuffed hoses down their
mouths and made them drink bleach he
could have been the founder of kwanzaa
but we're actually going to go to mug
club here and play a new game
raz or robot
uh do we do we do the intro here you
know what you know what no there's let's
just i don't know you gotta save
something youtube
piss off
[Music]
foreign